>>Robert Pronovost: Really trying to address
giving every student what they need,
and giving them that
differentiated instruction is
where the technology
really comes in handy.
Not only are they getting immediate
feedback and they're able to move
at their own pace, but then I'm
also able to support the students
who really need my support.
>>Today, what we are gonna talk
about is addition and subtraction.
If she gives away ten pencils, how
many pencils will Teresa have left?
I want you to think about it.
Is this addition or
is this subtraction?
>>So today when we started in
math, we sat down on the rug
and we were starting with
addition and subtraction.
We practice identifying
clue words and knowing
if we need to add or subtract.
>>How do we know we're
doing addition?
>>Boy: Because you said "and
all" and that means all together.
>>Pronovost: Once I felt that
students really were getting back
into the rhythm with
addition and subtraction,
that's when I move
them on to computers.
>>When you're at Planet Turtle,
you're doing your independent
practice.
You need to practice at least
three games, and you'll need to get
about eighty percent
correct in order to move
on to Dream Box, or to the iPods.
>>Planet Turtle is a program
that allows them to play games.
In these games, they are
being asked math questions.
Planet Turtle gives them immediate
feedback, whereas I would have
to walk around the entire
room to give them feedback.
By them getting their immediate
feedback through Planet Turtle,
I could grab some students who
really needed some support and work
with them in a small group.
>>Pronovost: Please show me on yours--
>>Girl: What is ten minus nine,
and then I know the answer,
so I click, and you get a point.
>>Pronovost: For the students who
were practicing on their own,
Planet Turtle was the way
to reinforce the addition
and subtraction that we
had practiced as a class.
Once they'd shown mastery in Planet
Turtle, they were able to move
on to Dream Box, and Dream Box gave
them that individualized instruction
at their own level, whereas Planet
Turtle was only providing a basic
practice for the entire
class at the same level.
>>I encourage my students to use all
the tools that are available to them.
One thing that we emphasize
in this class is
that using computers is
not always the best tool.
Using your hands may not
always be the best tool.
And so when I have some
students on Planet Turtle,
they might be solving the
problem on their white board,
or they might be counting
on their fingers,
because that's the
best strategy for them.
>>And our final answer would be?
>>All: Fourteen.
>>My first two years
that I was teaching,
I didn't have any technology
in my classroom.
Not having access to those tools
and knowing how valuable they could
be is what kind of drove me to reach
out to companies around, which led to
receiving a few computers from Apple,
and then recently receiving a
large grant from Facebook as well.
>>Girl: I wanna like practice a
little bit more, for I could get
like so much better here.
>>Pronovost: The iPod Touches
came to us through a SIG grant,
School Improvement Grant.
Dream Box we started this year.
We are just trying
out, on a trial basis,
because most of the software we
use in this classroom I either get
through beta testing
or through free trials.
>>Pronovost: The iPod Touch might be
valuable at one time for students
to practice a certain
strategy or game
and then the MacBooks might
support them in another way
with their leveled reading or with
differentiated math instruction.
>>What number do we have in
the tens place right here?
>>Boy: Four.
>>Pronovost: Four, what
are we subtracting?
>>Boy: One.
>>Pronovost: One group of ten, four
groups of ten minus one group of ten.
So let's see, four minus one.
>>Boy: Three.
>>Pronovost: Okay, three.
>>Every six to eight weeks, we take
a benchmark exam, so I can compare
where my students were
at the beginning
of the year to where they are now.
So I have seen some
great improvement.
I have data that shows that they're
improving at a much greater rate
than my students had
in the past two years
when I didn't have any
of these applications.
>>We all start right here,
what number is this right here?
>>All: One.
>>Pronovost: One, what number
is in the bottom right here?
>>Boy: Three.
>>Pronovost: Three; is
there more on the top
or is there more on the floor?
>>All: More on the floor.
>>Pronovost: More on the floor.
>>All: Go next door.
>>They are interacting in a much
more fun way than say, you know,
answering questions and then just
saying, "Yes, you passed, no,
you didn't, move on to the next one."
It's just a lot more
engaging and exciting to them.
>>Six. So now I'm gonna
take away three.
One, two...
>>Boy: Three.
>>Pronovost: Three.
>>Because they're games, they
are constantly being assessed.
They need to pass this in order
to move to the next level.
So while students feel
like, "Oh, I'm working.
I got to the next level,"
truly that means
that they've mastered this concept.
They're moving on to
the next concept.
It's just a new way of phrasing it.
>>Girl: Five minus two.
>>Girl: That's three.
>>Girl: Yeah, We did
this-- I did this on my--
>>Pronovost: Students could be
doing the same kind of practice
on a worksheet, but if they're
doing it on a worksheet,
they're going to get
very bored easily.
They're going to want to know
what to do when they're done,
because there's no built in levels
to move on to, so I wouldn't have
that time with the students who I
really feel need my time and support.